what's going on my friends Jason Silva
here now as you know I've spent the last
couple of years making content about
existentialism futurism relationship
singularity technology creativity and
what it means to be human
now I'm compelled to create this video
content no matter what and I give it out
to the world I give it to the world for
free however the price of these videos
is not free I have to cover costs for
editing's videography stock footage
travel costs etc so I finally decided to
join patreon and what that means is that
you guys can become supporters of my
work if my work has added value to your
life if you've become inspired by my
content here's your chance to support so
please consider becoming a patron of my
content by pledging a certain amount per
month whatever you can do it all helps
and hopefully we can meet the goal of
taking this content to the next level so
thank you so much for supporting me
throughout I love you guys and let's do
this